one cares on my board people are like
how did you get Gary on the board I was
like no no it was it was a cold call May
Ruth I'm sorry I interrupt that just
inspired me please understand how real
this is like every one of you probably
has four to seven people you're trying
to get to for whatever reason and it's
really there for the taking like when I
dm'd you it was actually a bet my friend
he's like a big fan of yours and then
your name just came up in conversation
one day he's like dude just go DM him
and like I bet you 100 bucks he's gonna
respond I'm like dude garyvee's not
respected he probably gets a thousand of
these every day we like made the BET and
we're like let's set a deadline I'm like
he's gonna reply by I gave up on him
like two weeks later you hit me up and
you're like yo thanks for the message
and you hook me up with Tyler right I
was like dude it's crazy like one dm
like I just like took a shot out of
nowhere it's what I want everybody to do
like you can get to people not everybody
I like people and want to meet people
and like that's my personality and guess
what there's other athletes and
actresses and models and skateboarders
and rappers that are like that too it's
not about a status it's about a mindset